so
[Music]
if therefore this meaning of the
objective is not to be mere imagination
it must possess intrinsic being must
originally appear in consciousness as
stemming from the notion and must come
forth in its necessity
it is thus that self-knowing spirit has
arisen for us that is through the
cognition of the immediate consciousness
or the consciousness of the object in
its immediacy through its necessary
movement this notion which as immediate
has also the shape of immediacy for its
consciousness has in the second place
given itself the shape of implicit
self-consciousness that is by just the
same necessity of the notion by which
being or the immediacy which is the
contentless object of sensuous
consciousness externalizes itself and
becomes the eye for consciousness
but the immediate in itself or the
necessity that simply is is itself
different from the in itself that thinks
or from the cognition of necessity a
difference however which at the same
time does not lie outside of the notion
for the simple unity of the notion is
immediate being itself
the notion is that once a
self-externalization or a coming to be
of intuitively perceived necessity and
also in this necessity is in communion
with itself knows it and comprehends it
the immediate in itself of spirit that
gives itself the shape of consciousness
means nothing else than that the actual
world spirit has attained to this
knowledge of itself
it is then too that this knowledge also
first enters into its consciousness
how that came about we have already seen
in paragraph 757 after all the cautions
in the previous paragraph now we're
moving
ahead although it may not seem so when
you're looking just at this paragraph
but if you look at the next several to
come
we're getting some consolidation
happening now this paragraph
757 is very very abstract but we get to
see it more concretely
in the next paragraph so you can just
sort of hold on and see
where we're going i should mention too
that hegel is using a lot of terms
over and over and over again
in here you know for example necessity
gets used quite a lot uh immediacy
consciousness even though the notion is
a few times and then on zeke
over and over again in this this
paragraph
and interestingly there's going to be a
distinction between
different kinds of on zeke right we're
going to have a thinking dank into on
zeke as well coming in
when you're reading this paragraph
anytime you're seeing reference to
intrinsic being
or the implicit it that's the in itself
the on zeke and i think miller's
translation
somewhat allied that by using several
different terms to translate on zeke
which by the way is you know kind of a
typical thing for not just hegel
translators but translators in general
to do to take an important term
and then you know render it different
ways in different sentences or
paragraphs
when you do that as a translator you
generally want to give some sort of
signal like putting the you know
original in brackets so that the
you know the person reading it in
english in this case actually knows that
the same term is being used
multiple times
be that as it may there's there's a lot
of important stuff happening here
and i thought we could kind of bookend
it in terms of
uh spirit right and the these two
discussions of what's happening with and
to and through spirit
in this paragraph
so he begins by saying if therefore this
meaning the badoitong of the objective
is not to be mere imagination which we
don't want it to be we saw this in the
previous paragraph right
then it must possess intrinsic being on
zeke right must originally appear in
consciousness as stemming from the
notion so the grief we're getting that
here this is an important term and must
come forth in its necessity another term
the no vendi kite that we've mentioned
we're going to see a lot of now
here's the first mention of spirit it is
thus that
self-knowing spirit has arisen
for us
right and
what is self-knowing self
viscende right
uh knowing itself in the sense
not just of
you know canon recognition
but
you could say understanding itself right
grasping itself in perhaps a
conceptual way so self-knowing spirit
religion is all about spirit right as we
saw from the beginning how are we
getting that he says that
through the cognition this is a term
that's going to show up several times
air cannon
and
well let's see where this goes and then
i want to come back to this term air
cannon
through the cognition of the immediate
consciousness
or of the consciousness of the object in
its immediacy
through its necessary movement so we're
seeing a lot of immediacy being talk
talked about here and you say well isn't
immediacy always a bad thing for hegel
it's not bad it's just you know
less developed
it requires being unpacked and showing
where the mediations lie
well we also sometimes do need immediacy
and if we see where we're going with
this you'll see why
immediacy is something desirable at this
place but air cannon so
why are kennen and not air kent niss
which is what we might expect right
there canon is a verb it's a verb that's
being turned into a noun here a process
of
you know getting to know of thinking
about of wrapping our heads around
something that is what allows spirit to
be
self-knowing but spirit must know other
things besides itself right
so he goes on and he says
this notion
which as immediate okay so that tells us
something right there
the notion when it's fully developed
should not be immediate
right
but
at the start of a process
the notion that we have with something
that begriff
can in fact be
rather immediate its immediacy has not
yet been revealed to us
phenomenologically through examining it
through working with it seeing how it
unpacks itself so it had the shape the
gestalt of immediacy for its
consciousness and then he says it has in
the second place given itself the shape
of
implicit
self-consciousness consciousness on zeke
right
so
this is an important idea
consciousness can be taken as sort of a
factum you know a brute thing that that
confronts us that we don't fully
understand but we are registering
so he goes on and then says um
that is
by just the same necessity of the notion
by which being or the immediacy which is
the contentless object of sensuous
consciousness
externalizes itself and becomes the eye
for consciousness now that's something
that we saw traced out
in the consciousness section right
let's remind ourselves of what we
attained
in that you know where we started with
sense certainty the sensuous object
which turned you know we think is the
most concrete and then turns out to be
the most abstract thing
as well as markers like space and time
you know now then
here there
we start looking at objects we realize
that they're things with properties but
there are things with properties not
just in themselves but for us the
conscious being there's a dialectic
going on between them we move into force
and the understanding things get way
more complicated very quickly but that's
what's being talked about here how does
that translate into
religion that's what we have to to see
so he goes on and he says it
externalizes itself right and we've been
talking about externalization now for
several paragraphs and becomes the eye
for consciousness that's a really
interesting turn of phrase isn't it
isn't it isn't i the consciousness
well
we externalize ourselves
and
we conceptualize
who we are
and that conceptualization that
sometimes we call the ego right
it's not entirely what we are as
subjects or as hegel is saying it here
as consciousness
and we have this interesting
polarity
between the two of them don't we
this is going to open the door for
something else to come in there and
fill it up
so he goes on and he says
the immediate in itself
or the necessity that simply is right
the the in itself over here
the on zeke that is immediate that is
part of what the notion is grasping
that's only
part of what's going on it's different
from
another in itself so the in itself is
being
split
with only the notion uniting it together
or you could say necessity
uh governing all of it
right
and he goes on and he says
it's different than the in itself that
thinks
or from the cognition
of necessity once again we see this term
air cannon
right the same air cannon that was the
cognition of immediate consciousness is
now
the cognition of necessity of note
vendikait of why things have to be the
way that they are why they turned out
the way that they are why
the concept looks the way that it does
so then he goes on and he says this is a
difference which at the same time does
not lie outside of the notion the notion
encompasses both of these because the
simple unity of the notion is immediate
being itself which seems to slide it
over to this side right the notion is at
once
two things
a self-externalization or a coming to be
of intuitively
perceived necessity and so
you know is that cognition of necessity
it could be
that
might also be over here on on the other
side though
or and also in this necessity he says it
is in communion with itself
knows it and comprehends it
so there's
a
unity through
cognitive means right knowing it um
and uh intuiting it comprehending it
um he goes on and says the the immediate
in itself of spirit
that gives itself the shape of
self-consciousness so immediate in
itself
again of spirit you can say how does
spirit have an immediate in itself well
go back to the previous couple
paragraphs substance becomes
self-consciousness right and here the
immediate in itself of spirit
through becoming self-consciousness
becomes spirit in another
way
actual
vehicle
spirit right that's already an
achievement spirit in the world spirit
that is worldly spirit that becomes
actual through
unpacking its its own you know
complex self
but here he's got a different word it's
not just spirit
geist it's
world spirit welt geist
right and
it's it's not producing
world spirit world spirit is something
that is emerging
what it is leading to however the the
immediate in itself is spirit through
self-consciousness
is leading to world spirit as hegel says
attaining to knowledge of itself
and then he says it is then too that
this knowledge
also first enters into consciousness
and then he's got this sort of nice
kicker how that came about we have
already seen now that's a bit misleading
to end the paragraph with because
have we really seen it yes kind of but
the next paragraph and the paragraph
after that is going to certainly tell us
a hell of a lot more about how that has
come to be
historically for world spirit but
we'll see where hegel
is going it's enough if we've gotten to
this point and comprehend um what is
happening here the next paragraph kind
of
helps us figure out what what he's what
he's aiming at with this
that absolute spirit has given itself
implicitly the shape of
self-consciousness and therefore has
also given it for its consciousness
this now appears as the belief of the
world that spirit is immediately present
as a self-conscious being
that is as an actual man
that the believer is immediately
certain of spirit sees feels and hears
this divinity
thus this self-consciousness is not
imagination but is actual in the
believer consciousness then does not
start from its inner life from thought
and unite within itself the thought of
god with existence
on the contrary it starts from an
existence that is immediately present
and recognizes god therein
the moment of immediate being is present
in the content of the notion in such a
way that the religious spirit
in the return of all essentiality into
consciousness has become a simple
positive self just as the actual spirit
as such in the unhappy consciousness was
just this simple self-conscious
negativity
the self of existence spirit has as a
result the form of complete immediacy it
is posited neither is something thought
or imagined nor as something produced as
is the case with the immediate self in
natural religion and also in the
religion of art on the contrary this god
is sensuously and directly beheld as a
self as an actual individual man
only so is this god self-consciousness
paragraph 758 is still full of all sorts
of metaphysical abstract language on
hegel's part but we are
centering in on something where we can
say aha i think i know where he's going
historically
concretely
in terms of this all all of what this
refers to the object
of this and its meaning so he tells us
that absolute spirit has given itself
implicitly once again we see the on zeke
right
uh the shape the gestalt of
self-consciousness
and therefore has also given it for its
consciousness right so we've got
consciousness self-consciousness the two
things that religion is supposed to be
connecting the religious spirit
then it has done this he says
this now appears
as the belief of the world
the glauben right
of the world so we should pause for just
a second on that what is the belief of
the world
is this what everybody in the world
believes obviously not because when it
comes to religion we're not all on the
same page even historically
within a religion that's developing some
people are like yeah you're going too
far with these developments man
you're turning into your own new
religion or your heretics or something
like that so obviously that's not the
case does it mean something like a
general recognition of what's happening
in the world
it depends i mean if we're thinking
about where this is going
in terms of
a single individual
religious
transformers founders consolidators
you know what they did mattered in a
part of the world but not the totality
of the world right away and at this
point we could be
thinking you know well maybe he has you
know jesus christ in mind
maybe he has uh siddhartha gatama the
leader of the buddha in mind maybe he
has zoroaster transformer of the uh and
in some ways puritan of the uh
traditional indo-iranian religion is
found in iran at the time and none of
them
all of them have world historical
importance but only later on so we have
to keep let's keep this in our back
pocket the belief of the world what is
it what is its content the belief of the
world
that
spirit
geist is immediately present
and again we see this
unmediatedness which we typically
associated with a lack of development
but sometimes it's just what we need
immediately present as what
a self-conscious being now this is a bit
of so
sign why not just call that
self-consciousness
well because miller wants to stress the
fact that we're talking about an
individual being a person right
but it is spirit is immediately present
as self-consciousness
so
you know does that mean that
it's sort of like spirit is in the world
and it sees itself and all of that
no we're moving away from that as a
matter of fact we're talking about a god
who is imminent who shows up in history
and makes a difference
at in very prosaic ways right so he goes
on and he says
immediately president is a
self-conscious being that is
as an actual now miller translates man
but very like a mensch right an actual
human being
now that's interesting isn't it
why a human being why not
something seemingly transcendent to
humans like you know an angel or i don't
know some some great you know improved
hominids kind of thing you know the
superman right
why not an animal why not something else
because we've already transversed
these different possibilities and now
we're zeroing in
not for the first time on the human
being i mean we saw this to some degree
in the previous
section of religion right human beings
mattered in that but this is a bit
different so he he goes on and he says
um that the believer is immediately
certain of as spirit so there's an
immediacy
meaning you can be in the presence not
just of spirit but of the person the
human being
who is self-conscious spirit
this is
pretty amazing
contrast this to as he's going to bring
up the unhappy consciousness where
there's always this distance right you
can be in the presence of the idols of
the god and you know pray and hope that
you can reach this distance now the
distance has been breached
god is right there in front of us at
least for for some of us i mean this is
about belief right the belief of those
in the religious community those who say
oh holy crap wow look at this and those
who
receive their testimony and come to
believe and become part of a community
and part of a tradition and a occultists
right
so how is this
encountered what is this immediate
certainty like well it involves seeing
feeling
hearing
and notice what hegel doesn't say here
thinking right that's going to be
contrasted against this and he tells us
that this is no longer imagined right
it's not just something that we're
projecting on to that guy over there who
doesn't feel like being god but we treat
them as god
but actual veer click
it is something that is real
for
the believer immediately certain of
spirit
and now here's a really other important
point thus this self-consciousness is
not imagination but actual in the
believer
so it's not just a belief that
this being
the god person
the actual person is
really god it's not just an imagination
but it is also in the believer
him or herself
so it's it's not
just a purely external relation
it's something that one receives and
takes into oneself
and in that way takes god into oneself
right
he goes on and he says consciousness
then does not start from its inner life
from thought
and unite within itself the thought of
god with existence so it doesn't begin
from a conception
of god and then say where am i going to
find this god let me look around where
where is this god actual where does this
god exist it's founded
if it believes if it chooses to have
faith
and he goes on and says
it starts from an existence that is
immediately present
and recognizes god therein so this is
the this is the challenge of revealed
uh religions
particularly those where it's not just
a founder or purifier saying oh no no
i'm not god i may be pretty good and
close to god but you know god is really
giving me stuff
this is a
greater
step
somebody who's willing to say oh no no
i am the divine object
i'm not just somebody who
mediates that for you it brings you a
revelation written down or something
like that or an ethical code or a set of
teachings sermons in a deer park or
something like that
i am what you've been looking for
i'm i'm the guy or
you know could be the
no reason why mensch couldn't be a woman
right in this case historically it's
going to be a guy
so he he goes on and he says
it starts from an existence immediately
present recognizes god therein the
moment of immediate being is present in
the content of the notion
in such a way that the religious spirit
so what we began with at the start of
this entire religion section
in the return of all essentiality into
consciousness has become
a simple positive self
just as the actual spirit of such and
the unhappy consciousness was
just this simple self-conscious
negativity so
as opposed to the unhappy consciousness
we have a genuine
positivity here that we can enter into
relation with that can enter into us
as the believer
and become part of who we are
and we can still continue to see feel
here so long as you know they're they're
alive right eventually a lot of it does
become imagination doesn't it right as
we see with the development of
christianity uh and and particularly
it's it's late post-modern forms which
you know are held by people who you know
decry the post-modern but they're as
post-modern as you can get you know lots
of imagination going on there
in any case he says we've got a single
simple positive self right so he says
the self of existence spirit has as a
result the form of complete
immediacy it is posited neither is
something thought or imagined
nor is something produced
so it's not just leaving aside the
thought or imagined
like being wrapped up in your own head
or your collective you know cult or
something like that it's also not
something produced why not because
production is what human beings do
production is not what human beings
themselves are i mean we could say well
you know
we are you know products of our family
hegel we could say yeah yeah that's fine
uh and you're going to learn a language
obviously but you are not simply
something that has been produced like an
idol or
other statuary or a temple although you
know we may use metaphors for that you
know the temple of my body or things
along those lines so he says it's not
something produced
as is the case with the immediate self
and natural religion and also in the
religion of art
so you know something thought or
imagined in natural religion something
produced in the religion of art and then
he says on the contrary this god is
sensuously and directly
now that's a plague asm on on
miller's part there's only one german
term there on chalica right beheld
self
um a self that is grasped as an actual
individual
person now no longer just veer click and
mensch but virtually
einstein
right an individuated
person and he says only so is this god
self-consciousness god becomes
self-consciousness
not as some sort of just cosmic
principle or transcendent deity who made
everything and judges everything
but as a person as a human being
like us but also
unlike us
and so you know this is where hegel is
going he's setting the stage to bring in
incarnation
you